some people in Hollywood do more than
make movies or headlines they are
citizens in the best sense of that good
word to honor the best of them the
Academy's Board of Governors
occasionally confers the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award this year it will be
presented by one of our best miss Betty
Davis
Charlton Heston served six terms as
president of the Screen Actors Guild a
post that provided two of his
predecessors with a springboard into the
political arena Chuck wants no part of
politics
I've played three presidents three
Saints and two geniuses he told me and
that should be enough to satisfy any men
but it does not satisfy us the Board of
Governors has voted him this award
because he is one of the most generous
gentlemen in the film community he has
been on the National Council of the Arts
for six years and is currently chairman
of the American Film Institute and the
center theater group in Los Angeles he
has performed countless services for the
motion picture and television fund
Planned Parenthood muscular dystrophy
the heart fund and the American Cancer
Society Chuck Heston has not done any of
these things for recognition or credit
it's just the way he is a man of
conscience and to boot a darn good
tennis player who turns even that hobby
into charity I am honestly proud to
present the Hersholt Humanitarian Award
to Charlton Heston
when Betty Davis says that you figure it
must be true but really I think I won
this award for doing the kind of chores
a whole lot of other people do too but
because I'm an actor when I do them they
take my picture nevertheless I'm very
glad very proud and very grateful to the
Academy to have this like all the awards
given tonight it represents the good
opinion of the men and women you do your
work with and always for all of us
that's the best praise of all thank you
very much